Hannibal Buress is now joined the stage
yeah and literally these people went
they with the real world it is what
these people went nuts when you came out
on stage yeah lazy it's bad crazy
is it do do you enjoy being recognized
wherever you go now or is it weird it
depends
I'm a very fickle person sometimes
people are rude and weird and I was on
the phone trying to find this stage yep
and then someone was just taken a
picture of me and other hey relax you
want a phone away
that's mad it's better looking up no but
I want to call it's not important I was
trying to find the stages it's chaos out
here and then a hat actually I was
planning a venue in the Bill Graham
Civic Auditorium over there yeah and so
they had a car waiting outside and I get
in the car and then it was to come here
the car was going the opposite way
oh no of innocent let me out and I'm
going to walk and you just walk the rest
of the way walk backward why I am very
pleased that you were out shared life is
moving in a it is moving like so well
come back we're doing all right you want
to go for a spin I'm very happy that you
around the world interacting with real
people like these people here it's
lively out here I feel like I feel like
we don't see RL we are we are else guys
the room five is coming up
sanika legend the legend that's easier
than doing bit right at playlist water
no I don't think I'm gonna get to say
hang on so I don't know if I get the
same response we'll see I would not the
same response
let's marry though not the same resistor
it's fair my way you can handle that